kontrovers ideologisch besetzt gilt als
schwierig das thema migration zwei
versierte schweizer regisseure greifen
es auf wie es unterschiedlicher nicht
sein könnte für mich überholt die
realität meistens die fiktion durchaus
80 lausanne im winter minus 15 grad
jede nacht das gleiche szenario menschen
die obdachlosen 50 dürfen rein
die anderen müssen draußen bleiben sabri
das obdach der neue film von fernand
melgar es ist der letzte teil seiner
trilogie über unsichtbare menschen
flüchtlinge asylbewerber menschen am
rand unserer gesellschaft
melgar regisseurs lausanne und selbst
als kind illegal in die schweiz gekommen
ist das was man einen engagierten
filmemacher net der filme macht um für
eine weltoffene schweiz einzutreten um
der migration ein gesicht zu geben
minute sowie annett die stärke einer
gesellschaft misst sich an ihren
schwächsten gliedern die obdachlosen die
ich in meinem film zeige sind
normalerweise unsichtbar
man sieht sie nicht auf der straße viele
schweizer sind verwundert dass zehn
prozent der menschen in der schweiz in
prekären verhältnissen wird diese
obdachlosen verstecken sich sie wollen
sich nicht zeigen in diesem reichen land
weil sie es nicht schaffen an diesem
wohlstand teilzuhaben
melgar arbeitet streng dokumentarisch er
beobachtet er kommentiert nicht und
nähert sich dabei auf unnachahmliche
weise seinen protagonisten
er zeigt die abgewiesenen aber auch die
abweisenden er zeigt deren dilemma
zwischen der verpflichtung sich an
gesetze zu halten und dem bedürfnis zu
helfen
in meiner theologie habe ich situationen
beobachtet die durch volksentscheide
entstanden sind
für mich geht es nicht nur um die
umsetzung dieser entscheide sondern auch
um diejenigen die sie umsetzen müssen es
wäre ein leichtes zu sagen dass sie die
bösen sind nicht viel aber man versteht
in diesem film dass diese menschen
versuchen gesetze umzusetzen
das was die schweizer bürger was wir
entschieden haben nämlich nein zu sagen
die türen zu verschließen elementare
grundrechte zu verweigern ich suche
heimleitung kannst du mir sagen wo ist
heimleiter um engagierte
hilfsbereitschaft gegenüber
asylbewerbern geht es auch im spielfilm
schweizer helden eine fiktive geschichte
in der die hauptfigur aus egoistischen
gründen hilft regisseur peter luisi hat
zwei wochen in einem durchgangszentrum
recherchiert der film ist inspiriert von
einer realen geschichte ein heikler
stoff für eine komödie die haltung des
regisseurs ist aber klar
ich finde ein feelgood movie der viele
klischees bedient und sehr leicht
daherkommt für mich ein guter film im
film wo und raubten die klimageschichte
vor emotionen spüren
aber ich wette auf den filmen inhalt hat
das thema mint geschichte erzählt wird
es da gehabt
im vergleich sind es eindeutig mehr gas
bilder seiner realen geschichten über
unsichtbare die auffüllen
die uns umtreiben ein wahrer
heldenhafter film